[Music]
completely in love with him nothing
could be better
kaley cuoco is totally smitten with her
beau of a year and a half professional
horseback rider Carl cook why is he so
special he is totally the guy I think
the common denominator is the horses it
just works for us you know we have this
special bond and yeah the animals and he
he's as real he's so real I've never met
a kinder human being he's gentle and
he's real encourages me to do things
that are outside of my comfort zone like
mountain biking and dirt biking and I
did it and now I'm like obsessed and I
had the best time he's just getting me
to be more adventurous than I am ET
spoke with Kayleigh on Sunday in
Hollywood before she hosted the annual
stand up for Pitts benefit an
organization dedicated towards saving
the lives of pitbulls I think the only
person that loves your dogs more than
you do is Carl oh me are you planning on
getting a dog together are you gonna
expand the brood you got three Carl
informs me actually a few days ago that
he was wanted to rescue another bulldog
so I think we're gonna go get another
bulldog a lot of stigma surrounding pit
bulls as an owner yourself set the
record straight I I feel that every dog
is inherently good I think it's how
they're raised I don't care if it's a
pit bull a chihuahua German Shepherd if
they're raised in a loving home they're
gonna be a loving dogs I will support
them and scream them from the rooftops
as long as I live the best dogs I've
ever had
[Music]
you
[Music]